kylie jenner is summoned to speak under  oath on behalf of her boyfriend Tyga a  judge is taking a closer look at Tyga's  finances loopy girlfriend Kylie into the  rapper's legal drama donít on it in 2013  the Rack City rapper was sued by  celebrity jeweler Jason of Beverly Hills  who claimed Tyga owed him over 270,000  dollars in unpaid jewelry expenses  according to court docs obtained by ET  Kylie and Tyga are both required to come  in for questioning to examine the  rapper's source of income and can the  jeweler's attorney Danny a beer tells us  he plans to ask the reality star about  the lavish gift she received from Tyga  for her 19th birthday including this  two-hundred-thousand-dollar black may  bag happy birthday to you happy the  lawyer has agreed to question Kylie in a  private setting outside of the  courthouse  you